AI involves developing computer systems
that can perform tasks typically
requiring human intelligence it entails
creating intelligent machines that can
perceive reason learn and make decisions
based on acquired knowledge this
technology has found applications in
numerous Industries including Healthcare
Finance Transportation entertainment and
more it has been used to develop virtual
assistant autonomous vehicles fraud
detection systems personalized
recommendation and medical diagnosis
systems among many other applications
the widespread adoption of AI presents
exciting career opportunities in various
Industries and sectors roles like AI
Engineers data scientists NLP Engineers
computer vision Engineers AI research
scientists robotic engineers and many
more offer exciting prospects for
working with cutting-edge Technologies
and making an impact through AI
Innovation according to Glassdoor the
average reported salary of an AI
engineer in United States is around 105
000 dollars per year however in India it
is 10 lakh Rupees per annum the impact
of AI on the workforce is complex and
evolving while it automates tasks and
creates new job opportunities requiring
human expertise in development
deployment and maintenance AI generates
new fields and roles like AI ethics
Specialists data scientists and AI
trainers humans can focus on higher
value work collaborate with AI and
contribute in areas requiring creativity
empathy and critical thinking AI has
played a pivotal role in creating a wide
range of tools that significantly
improve individuals life here are some
notable examples of AI power tools that
has made a positive impact such as voice
assistance Siri Google assistant and
Amazon Alexa offer hands-free assistant
for tasks like reminders music playback
and smart home control the next one is
personalized recommendations platforms
like Netflix and Spotify use AI to
suggest personalized movies shows and
songs based on user preference the
virtual customer service EI chat boards
provide instant 24x7 customer support
and troubleshooting assistance language
translation AI translation tools like
Google translate provide a quick and
accurate translations in real time
personal health and fitness assistant AI
powered Health apps and wearables track
activities monitor sleep and offer
personalized Health insights smart home
automation AI enables voice control
Smart devices for lighting thermostat
and security cameras enhancing
convenience and Energy Efficiency these
examples demonstrate how AI has made
individuals lives easier as AI
technology progresses we can anticipate
further Innovative applications that
will enhance various aspects of daily
life so are you seeking a Competitive
Edge in the era of Advanced Technologies
look no further than caltex Ai and
machine learning bootcamp developed in
collaboration with Caltech to propel
your career as an AIML specialist this
comprehensive program offers life
classes led by industry experts Hands-On
Labs industry relevant projects and
exclusive master classes conducted by
Caltech professors this course offers
key features such as up to 22 CEUs from
Caltech ctme bootcamp certificate from
caltex ctme caltex ctme Circle
membership online convocation by Caltech
ctme program director industrial
relevant Capstone projects in three
domains 25 Hands-On projects with
integrated labs and simply learns career
service for enhanced job opportunities
Ai and machine learning boot camp is the
perfect choice for those seeking a
competitive advantage in the era of
cutting-edge Technologies the curriculum
offers comprehensive training in AI
based Technologies including ml NLP deep
learning speech recognition
reinforcement learning and more this
course covers a range of essential
skills including statistics Python
Programming supervised learning
unsupervised learning recommendation
systems natural language processing or
NLP neural networks deep learning and
many more along with these skills the
course also covers various tools and
Technologies such as python tensorflow
Keras matplotlib and many more a mark on
the exciting industry projects that
provides a hands-on experience and
practical insights so hurry up and find
the course Link in the description box
for more details our Learners have
experienced huge success in their areas
listen to their experience find the
simple lens course reviews Link in the
description box the next cohort is
starting soon to know more about this
intensive training program which imparts
a job ready skills and prepares you for
the career as an AI engineer check out
the course Link in the description box
with this we have come to the end of the
top AI bootcamp for 2023. if you like
this video subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn if
you need any help in opting for this
course please let us know in the comment
section below we will get back to you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign